all right some questions from the
mailbag let's get to as many as we can
john pascal has a great question if the
head coaching hire doesn't matter for
desean watson and it was
chris morton reported over the weekend
watson wants out regardless of who they
hire to be the coach
what is watson waiting for in terms of
asking for a trade let me take a crack
at this one shireen i think that
watson knows the moment he says trade me
it's over it's done and if they say
no he has to move to the next square
on the flow chart which would be never
show up again
potentially pay back a bunch of money
potentially hold out into the regular
season
potentially say goodbye to shireen we'll
try to get her back
as we as we work through this but i
think that that's why he's waiting he
doesn't want to make an
idle threat he doesn't want to make an
empty request when he says trade me
he wants that message to have true
potency
he wants the texans to know it's over
it's done
and there is no going back which implies
that at least for now
there may be a way to get him to turn
around there could be
an opportunity to get deshaun watson to
change his mind but
i think this is more him coming to terms
with what happens next
after he has to be traded all right
shireen would have said the same thing
at oscar 904 is jacksonville really as
bad as randy moss makes it seem
i assume he means randy moth the former
receiver not randy moss the nfl network
employee who does some work for nbc as
well
either way i don't know what randy moss
says about jacksonville does he say bad
things about jacksonville did you say
bad things about the jaguars
look this is a team that has shown in
the past that it can be competitive
they've lost their way in recent years
they were on the brink of the super bowl
just three years ago they had the
patriots down and out in the fourth
quarter a bad call
is what saved the patriots in that game
not anything the jaguars did so
you've got urban meyer jury's out on
whether or not he's going to be a great
nfl head coach
you've got trevor lawrence who's
undoubtedly going to be the first
overall pick in the draft so we we see
what happens but
i wouldn't rule out the jaguars as a
team that can get competitive
very quickly and uh shireen you're still
there
any thoughts on jacksonville
i i spent a lot of time there i lived in
daytona for a couple years i
you know it's yeah it's not the best
part of florida but
you have to want to go there with what
they have
and and look the jaguars i think have
the potential to become
a competitive team and those fans
deserve it along with the fans in the uk
they get to see the jaguars
once or twice a year hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports